[Music]
definitely some experience with the
chess for joe montana and
uh whenever you're ready just make your
first move
got it okay there we go oh and he's
already moved
okay here we go and i'm going
to move
okay so joe develops his queen very
early on the offensive
on the attack magnus does play instantly
as we know
okay solid start from joe ping the pawn
pushing another pawn it looks like in a
moment it's playing quickly this is good
trying to get as many moves as possible
magnus meanwhile don't like that move
moving a rook
that is very unconventional david i've
never seen
anything like that before and uh joe is
doing some great stuff he's developing
his pieces now will he get his knights
out
um it looks like he's about to push a
pawn he's going to attack the opponent's
bishop that looks good to me kicking
that bishop all the back
all the way back where it came from now
joe needs to develop those pieces as you
mentioned ivanka
get those pieces out playing quickly
he's got one minute 10
left on his clock he needs to maybe up
the pace if he wants to break the
existing record of number of moves
played
and uh magnus age 10 is being sneaky he
is
challenging those pawns that joe
has pushed up the board and you can see
that magnus is not caring about material
he
just wants to develop his knight and uh
what are we gonna see joe do
he has to speed up he has 50 seconds
left on the clock
yeah he's playing well he's got a great
position but he does need to develop
pieces
and get more moves as quickly as
possible allowing now
black's knight into the center of the
board maybe a bit of a slip there
but okay he does have the opportunity to
develop now
okay 35 seconds come on joe let's get
those moves on the board
okay he looks like he's about to push
another pawn and now we're under 30
seconds
and joe has to play faster
he needs to start making moves it's not
the time to think
it's about playing as many moves as
humanly possible 20 seconds left he
needs to get those moves quick and fast
now
forget about their objective value just
get those moves on the board
and okay it looks like he's moving a
rook good move
um there but okay 10 seconds less than
10 seconds now for joe
five seconds can he make another move
one more move joe
push report and push a knight ah he runs
out of time
and it's over and if you press continue
joe
we're gonna see how many moves you
lasted 13 moves
13 moves all right
yeah yeah 13 moves that must be good how
do you feel about your game joe
that's ted that's ten moves more than i
expected
sounds good that is very good
excellent i was born on the third
i must say at the end you had a great
position actually
actually that's the best position that
any celebrity has ended with
in the challenge so far wow wow
did you hear that joe the best position
any celebrity has been in
well i i have to like i said i wanted to
move quickly my feeling was to not try
to overthink it
and just kind of take to take the board
in as an impulse
and just go with it uh so i'm happy with
that i'm happy with 13. considering i
haven't
played a full game of chess probably
since we did the movie bobby
all right well let's uh take a look at
the scoreboard where this places you
on the celebrity challenge so we had
whoa it's actually the same as sal khan
13 moves it is bottom of the table
though but uh
well a lot can happen here how do you
feel about uh
the result joe i'm very like i said i'm
very happy considering that i
expected to lose a lot quicker yeah uh
yeah
and uh but that's fine and like i said
but i enjoyed it i like the fact that
it forces you to just kind of you know
you use your brain and
that whole visual mental
all the things that makes chess the game
that it is and is why it's had the
endurance it has
and why you know it you know it has the
worldwide
appeal that it does
you